welcome back to my round three game from
theu Gyra Blitz tournament now this one
started off a little bit strangely
because when the round began my opponent
was nowhere to be seen and what I could
have done was start the clock and get
some early timeouts but I didn't want to
do that because unlike the previous
rounds where the pairings went up online
in round three the pairings only went up
on the wall chart inside the playing
room my opponent ended up telling me
after the game that he was late to this
round because he was continually
checking the pairings online they
weren't being posted so he assumed the
round wasn't started it was only a few
minutes after the round officially
started that he arrived So eventually
yeah we do shake hands and our game
begins I think we were maybe both a
little bit flustered but we do start the
game he plays D4 I play D5 he plays the
Queen's Gambit and then he realizes is
that he had his phone in his pocket so
he took it out but he forgot to hit his
clock after playing C4 so there's a
small awkward moment there but finally
uh yeah we return to some normaly and we
go into the same opening that I had in
my first round game this is a Queen's
Gambit declined exchange variation and I
repeat this move Bishop to D6 the
so-called Kasa corle variation uh one of
my favorite pet lines and we were both
blitzing out some opening theory he
plays Queen C2 I play Rook E8 this is
all still
preparation and he takes a pause in this
position there's a couple uh different
options for white uh between developing
the kingside Knight to E2 or
F3 and from my experience a lot of Queen
Gambit players are not specifically
prepared for this line a lot of players
just kind of go along with a typical
setup so I figured that uh that's
basically what's happening to my
opponent here and uh yeah White's
position is solid but it's always nice
playing this from the back side where I
have a lot more preparation in store and
what we're going to see from early on in
this game my opponent taking time on uh
a lot of moves and I'm just still
blitzing out A5 A3 Knight
A6 now even though he's played A3 to
prevent Knight B4 I still go with Knight
A6 because I want to maneuver my knight
eventually to C7 now with Bishop G3 I
take on G3 this is still preparation on
my part white can take back with a pawn
or with a
knight I do want to note here that this
line that we're going into I actually
played in an over theboard classical
game back in June it was the 1,000 gm uh
super Swiss tournament in Las Vegas and
I'm pretty pretty sure I still had this
exact position after H5 H3 and
H4 so I'm still basically just rattling
off some prep uh with H4 I'm attacking
his Knight and he has to choose whether
to move forward to F5 or Retreat to
E2 um I knew in the moment that if he
moves forward with Knight F5 then uh
sometimes a knight can get stuck there
so I think he was still just trying to
to figure out and understand the
position and this is a nice benefit with
being very prepared in a Blitz game I
really haven't had to figure out the
position at all and I'm still blitzing
out moves after knight2 I played knight6
and my Knight has found nice Central
Square so going forward from this
position I'm really looking to focus my
play on the king side now he plays this
move Knight to A4 which is a a very
typical idea for white he's looking to
maneuver the Knight to C5 and probably
expand with eventual minority attack uh
very likely Pawn B4 coming but I'm
focused on the king side I play Knight
H5 which uh looks maybe a little bit
strange to put the Knight on the edge of
the board but it does open up some lines
for my queen uh I have ideas of Queen F6
or queen
G5 and I want to note here that I'm
already up over 2 minutes on my clock I
have more time than I started with he's
hovering around 3 minutes but once he
plays KN C5 I'm pretty much out of my
specific
preparation and now I have to figure out
what to do with this tension between the
knights I could take on C5 and trade a
bit and then look to open my bishop or I
can avoid the trade and I do decide to
avoid the trade with Knight
G5 and with this move my knight and my
Bishop are aimed towards H3 Pawn so he
obstructs uh at least my Bishop from
aiming at H3 Pawn with Bishop F5 because
it was very likely I had ideas of
sacrificing an H3 but he's looking to
just neutralize any potential attack
that I have and now I have to decide do
I take the bishop on F5 do I leave the
tension between the Bishops so I
hesitate
here and I play Pawn to G6 which I think
is is a useful move uh supporting my
knight on H5 and provoking his Bishop on
F5 to move and this basically provokes
him to trade on C8 it would be a waste
of time if he were to retreat back to D3
in this position so he takes I take with
the queen to make sure my B Pawn B7 Pawn
is
defended and with the queen on C8 there
are still maybe some ideas of
sacrificing on H3
so he's still taking time here and I'm
still up about 2 minutes on the
clock now this position even though I've
been very well prepared in the opening
it's still relatively solid for both
sides we can see by the evalar that it's
close to equal so this is really just
the beginning of what's going to be a
very long battle and he plays this move
Knight D3 which uh very solid
centralizing move it does potentially
support I ideas of eventually Knight E5
or Knight to
F4 but it does allow me to bring my
queen in to
F5 and this does pin the Knight on D3 to
his undefended Queen on C2 so he plays
Rook C1 which defends the queen
essentially unpinning his Knight on
D3 and now I begin taking sometime uh
cuz I pretty much optimize my queen and
both Knights my my Rooks are decently
placed as well and I'm really trying to
figure out a plan going forward here it
feels like I'm in like pretty good shape
to attack on the king side and I'm
looking at sacrifices like taking on H3
or maybe eventually Knight to F3 but I
don't want to play recklessly and
sacrifice material without any
reasonable
compensation so I go into the tank as my
opponent he kind of looks around looks
at me looks around again
and this is where my time Advantage does
begin to dissipate a little bit now I'm
only up about a minute on the
clock and I play this move Knight to E4
which is somewhat of a multi-purpose
move uh on one hand I do centralize a
knight I tie down White's Rook to
defending F2 and I'm also making way for
my G Pawn uh now that my G Pawn is not
blocked by the Knight I do have ideas of
of G5 and G4 to try and uh just bust
open the king Side open the G file and
have more Avenues to attack now he plays
this move Knight
C5 returning to the square the Knight
came from a few moves ago and now he's
really just trying to to trade and if I
take his Knight then we could trade
Queens so I definitely didn't want to
trade Queens when I have more attacking
potential I played this move Rook E7 to
prepare the double up of Rooks he takes
my knight on
e4 and now I have a choice what to take
back with I think all three recaptures
are viable here although again I didn't
want to take on e4 with the queen to
allow the trade so I was mainly debating
between Rook takes E4 and pawn takes
E4 and I figured that pawn takes E4 is
the nicest way to imbalance the position
he offered the queen trade again again I
declined with Queen to
F6 and very soon we're going to see the
downside of my unwillingness to trade
queens and really try and carry through
with the king's side attack cuz even
though Queen F6 looked like a very
sensible move it does give white time to
focus on his own play and he played this
very sensible move Knight C3 and one of
the issues with my position is my queen
side is little a little bit
delicate with the structure that I
currently have and White's Pawn on D4
white is now threatening Pawn D5 uh
which would be supported by the Knight
and the Queen and it's not the easiest
move to stop here and meanwhile it's
still not easy for me to orchestrate the
attack on the king side like if I play
G5 then I'm risking overextending and
weakening my own
King so again I take some time and play
Knight to G7 trying to maneuver back
towards the
center and then he plays Pawn to D5 and
this is a very powerful move because if
I take the pawn he'll take back with a
knight and Fork my queen and my Rook so
I uh had to come up with something else
I play Rook E5 to pin the pawn to his
Queen but then he simply plays Queen B6
and on one hand it seems like he's
abandoning the D5 Pawn but he's actually
pinning my C6 Pawn to my Queen and at
the same time he's also attacking my
undefended Pawn on
B7 and all of a
sudden my queen side feels like it's
about to crumble and I figured that the
best approach is just to let the queen
side crumble and focus on the king side
now he was very closer to playing Queen
takes B7 which would have been a good
move but he hesitated a bit and instead
he takes on
C6 which allows me just to recapture and
maintain the material
equality however with this
transformation my C6 pawn and my A5 Pawn
on the queen side are quite
weak and he starts with the move Rook C
to D1 getting to the only open file in
the position and now I still have to
figure out do I have any clear ways to
attack on the king side and I figured
that I might as well scratch my head
before making a move and then align my
Rook with his King and with this move
I'm setting up the idea of Queen F3 if I
get one more move to play Queen F3 then
life would be very very good to uh just
create some maing attack on the king
side but uh he was clearly aware of my
threat and he plays the very very strong
resourceful move Knight D5 and I can't
take the Knight because my C Pawn is
still pinned to my queen and the move I
want to play here is Queen
F3 but that would walk into Knight F4
after which my queen would actually be
stuck on F3 and his G2 Pawn would be
defended by his Knight and if we imagine
Queen F3 Knight F4 he'd then be
threatening King H1 to unpin his G pawn
and then trap my queen on F3 so as much
as I wanted to go in for the kill with
Queen F3 I eventually concluded that
Queen F3 just doesn't work it would be a
blunder on my part and I had to figure
out a backup plan as I think I've
already fallen Below on time I'm uh yeah
getting severely severely low I'm trying
to find some alternative in the position
I play the move Queen F5 to uh just save
my queen but then he still plays his
Knight to F4 and my attack is just
non-existent here his Knight is so solid
on the king side I play Rook f8 in panic
he takes my free Pawn on C6 I play
Knight H5 trying to get rid of his
Knight on F4 and we do trade on H5
Knight takes H5 Rook takes H5 but now my
attack is basically non-existent here
offers a queen trade I uh I avoid
trading Queens just trying to keep some
hopes alive he plays Rook to D4
improving and things are not looking
good for me trying to get some
counterplay on the B file but after the
trade of Pawns he has now a pass Pawn on
B4 and uh everything seems to be going
in White's favor here Rook C1 very
useful move I improve my king
slightly and then he plays this move
Queen D6 and this actually gives away
White's whole Advantage because after we
trade Queens I win the pawn on B4 and
now we have a rook ending it's two Rooks
and four pawns against two Rooks and
four pawns and thankfully I uh I still
have enough time uh with the three
second increments I won't be
flagging and now both of us are like
pretty pretty solid even though there's
some imbalance with the structure I do
control a bit more space with pawns on
H4 and E4
uh this position is objectively equal
and for the next several moves we just
dance around with our Rooks and this is
really just a beginning of what's going
to be a very long endgame grind I really
really wanted to play for win here
despite the fact the position is
objectively equal I think we both knew
that at this
point and then with this move Pawn G3
this is basic what I was waiting for cuz
it imbalances the position even though
we do trade pawns white now has two Pawn
Islands a pawn and H3 and then the the
group of Pawns on F2 and E3 while I'm
keeping my very solid Pawn chain with
the three connected pawns and now with
the trade of Rooks we enter a slightly
different phase of the game where it's
all about trying to optimize my king and
rook and we're going to see just a long
endgame grind going forward from here my
opponent playing somewhat of a waiting
game I'm trying to at least get my Rook
to an acto
Square he plays Rook B8 I play King
H6 he plays
H4 doesn't change the position too much
I play Rook to
D1 now I am trying to set up rook to G1
check and then maybe plot my Rook on G4
so he gives me a check and then moves
back to A8 I give the
check he hesitates a little bit there
plays King
H2 and I get my Rook to G4 so cutting
off his King uh but the problem still is
it's hard for me to make progress cuz
whenever I move up my king his Rook is
ready to deliver the check and force me
back so it's still a frustrating
position and he did some fake out move
with the Rook there but uh yeah white is
still playing the waiting game and I'm
still trying to find any ounce of
winning chances I can get uh really just
trying to squeeze water from Stone here
uh a small crowd is beginning to form
this did turn out to be the last game of
the round uh especially cuz we started
late and now we're in this very long
grindy end game and I decide to transfer
my Rook to a different square and now I
jump on the opportunity to play this
move Pawn F4 I'm exploiting the fact
that his E3 Pawn is pinned to his King
and this is what I've been waiting for
I'm now winning a pawn I take on E3 he
takes I take after so much persistence I
finally won a pawn in the position
however it's really not enough because
after I play the move Rook H3 he takes
my Pawn on e4 I take his Pawn in H4
and his King just comes back and this is
a theoretical draw now a position like
this I did not want to take a draw
immediately generally especially in Rook
endings if you're up a pawn you should
really just play it out and and test
your opponent to see if they can draw it
uh the problem is when I have a g pawn
my ideas to try and trick my opponent
are very very limited and my opponent is
really just waiting with his Rook like
he puts his King in front of my king and
his rook's just waiting and I found it
just very difficult to make any sort of
progress or generate any sort of Tricks
so I think what I'll do is I'll stop
talking now and I'll let the video play
out maybe I'll even take away the
diagram so we can see the crowd's
reactions uh maybe I'll add some
dramatic music too but once the game
ends I'll come back and share my final
thoughts so enjoy the finish and stay
tuned for the final takeaways to this
[Music]
game
and the game ends King versus King a
peaceful finish to what was a very hard
fought battle I was in trouble earlier
in the game but then I thought my
opponent was maybe in trouble in the end
game but he defended very well and I
think a draw was a fair result and
before I wrap up the video I do want to
highlight some of the key moments in
this game it was a nice bit of opening
prep on my part I was prepared through
about 16 moves like through 96 pretty
sure I've had this position in my uh my
prep file before and I knew the ideas of
Knight H5 and Knight G5 and queen F6 and
trying to attack uh but my opponent
handled the opening very well and the
surprising thing about this game was I
was really never bad better in this game
like even in the end when I won the pawn
in the end game uh position was just
equal and I'll just go ahead and show
the engine graph uh maybe there was a
small moment stockfish slightly
preferred my position but uh yeah I was
actually very fortunate that I didn't
just lose this game and my opponent did
have a few chances to put me away in
this game so I want to show uh my
biggest blunder in this game was coming
up after Queen to
C5 uh I just made the wrong strategic
decision uh I was so set on trying to
attack on the king side I didn't want to
trade Queens but when I played Queen F6
this just gave white the advantage
because of the idea uh D5 was just a
very strong idea in the position and I
didn't really have any concrete way of
attacking so what I should have done in
this position was understand the fact
that my attack is really not going to
happen and I should have traded Queens
after takes takes I'd be in time to play
Knight F6 controlling the D5 square and
preventing white from playing D5 and
this position would have been
objectively equal but when I play Queen
F6 uh the position is just better for
white because white has all the clear
play and it wasn't really clear what I'm
supposed to be doing here uh especially
when white plays D5 opponent played
really strongly uh these several moves
maybe should have taken on B7 instead
but what he came up with was also like
pretty strong as Knight D5 move and uh
yeah just to show this on the board if I
were to play Queen
F3 even though this looks close to
winning for black it's actually just
losing because once white plays Knight
F4 this defends upon PA White's going to
play King H1 or King H2 next move and my
queen has no Escape uh so this position
is just completely winning for white so
thankfully I realize that I uh I avoided
Queen
F3 but uh yeah the position was just
easier to play for white after losing
the pawn I played this move Knight H5
and this is where my opponent missed a
very big knockout blow um very simple
tactic actually if you want to try and
pause the video white to move basically
finish off black in this position the
move is Rook to D5 skewering my queen to
The Rook and my queen doesn't have any
safe Square to keep the Rook defended
like Queen F6 just Queen takes F6 and
I'm just losing a lot of material if my
opponent were to play this so I was very
fortunate he didn't find Rook D5 and
then later in the game I was fortunate
that he gave me some mercy and played
this move Queen to D6 uh just giving
away the B Pawn and also giving away the
whole Advantage uh what he could have
done was played Rook C5 again missing a
skewer on the fifth ring
and uh yeah I'd have to play Queen F6
I'd allow The Rook trade and white would
go up a second Pawn here with uh just
full control very good chances to win
the game from here so even though I was
the one pushing towards the end and uh I
did eventually go up a pawn I really
never had a shot at winning this game
and uh I should be very fortunate to
have held on for a draw so that
concludes round three I know it was a
long one but hope you guys enjoyed it if
you have any questions about the game
leave them below and if you like the
content hit the like button subscribe it
does help the channel and stay tuned for
the next one see you guys soon